When you meet with me about when ultrasound, I was asking you about recurrent rash. You said you would do some research on that.
Yes, the recurrent rash that you were having, the couple possibilities that I came up with was possible viral infections.
As one cause of recurrent rash, it's possible that so when you're exposed to something that stimulates in a mute response like a bug bite or a poison ivy, if you get these rashes or something that stimulates a cytokine response, a very strong cytokine response.
The person gets a rash for a period of time. The other thing that I was looking at some literature is that it's possible that it's that there's a viral connection.
So the problem with viruses is that some of them are possible to kill. Some people, some theories are that they may not even be living organisms.
So it's you can basically knock them down, but they can never go away. You can basically test every single person in the world for Epstein bar and 90 some percent of the people will test positive for Epstein bar.
Why do people once you have, once you get a herpes virus that leads to coalsource, why do you get coalsource them throughout your life when you expose to lemon water or something like that because the virus lives in the ganglion of the nerve and it just comes out in opportunistic times.
Sometimes those opportunistic times, well, for a virus might be a change in pH like like a herpes of the mouth, but some opportunistic times are when there's a huge cytokine response.
So that's a possibility. You could try running the viral complex to see if that is it. There's also Epstein bar. There's other viruses so we don't know if it's Epstein bar, but Epstein bar is very common.
I'm running that program. I think there's a psoriatic program. Oh, the one question I was going to ask with you with that rash. Do you get any other symptoms with it like joint pain?
That could give us different clues to different issues too.
So if there's any other symptoms that you get with it, then that can give you an idea what possibly it is. No like fatigue or anything like that with it.
That would point more to Epstein bar. Then I would still maybe just run that instead. If that's not it, then I would run the viral complex. See if that helps knock it down.
You could also run the parasite all kill frequency. Was that covers a wide range? I'm different parasite frequency. See if that is it. Those are the things that I would try if I were you.